it's dangerous and we're gonna find out
yeah we're gonna find out there's three
sensible moves oh which way is he going
with the king he's put his king on the
bad square but now the knight comes in
and white is completely winning now this
night move sacrificing the night wins
for napomniachi because after pawn takes
night this is just going to end in
checkmate the rook's swinging across
this way and will the players react i
don't think they've spotted being in
vain
yeah of course that's how quickly things
can change just one wrong move
especially when your king is open when
there's no defensive pieces around your
king i mean things will change 360 if
you just take your eye off the ball for
one move that's what he did and
poor guy head in his hands now
it's too late as well there's no turning
back checkmate is threatened white's
queen is going to swing across black is
going to have to give up some material
to try and at least at least he can feel
better after this game knowing that i
fell for the same trick
that's not going to make him feel better
obviously i'm just saying that'll make
him feel a lot worse but um yeah it's uh
it's incredible actually how this is
turned on this move yeah yeah taking
under one minute
that's why you have to be so careful
when it comes to king city
and also psychologically he's been in
control as black the whole game he's had
the advantage the whole game and just
won this the worst worst way to lose
when you're actually being controlling
the game you played a really nice game
you've been out playing your opponent
which he has done look at him yeah and
and you suddenly lose that is the worst
way to